good
morning Millennials don't mind us Jackie
and I are just plotting how to spend our
honeymoons together yeah well we had an
idea while ago like maybe we all got a
house
she's taking her honeymoon I'm taking my
honeymoon but like honestly I love Ben
so much but like 10 days together it's
like so boring like we need friends so
maybe like we spend some time together
and then we go like if we had a big
house we sound like we could like not
see each other yeah like congregate for
dinner
I don't know and now I'm kind of
understanding people who take their
honeymoons right after their wedding
because all the time I could make you
forget at a time all I wanted was to be
bored and that's exactly what you have
ten days on your honeymoon but now I'm
like back in the swing of things like
where are we going where we party you're
gonna take me away from life for ten
days I don't think so it's just getting
good my extension collection just
launched but you can't just pick up and
leave you have a business I have a
business multiple thriving businesses I
really do I have missed businesses that
are breaking websites which is just so
exciting and even though it's annoying
for you guys and I'm sorry just be
patient website is up it's just working
slowly it is a good problem to have
because everyone just wants some hair
and that means I get free hair
oh I prayer I have free hair for you oh
you do yes what color what shade is this
this is shade number four it is no but I
believe yes so I used to think I was
like better than everyone like I didn't
need extensions but I've since cut my
hair and I cut it too short and hold on
let me just take this out so it stops
making sound um I used to think I was
better than everyone that couldn't need
extensions but wow it's really soft let
me see it doesn't match your hair I kind
of just I bought Ohio's oh my god
perfect match a princess so um I cut my
hair and then Taylor should have taught
me that when you once you turn 30 your
hair changes forever and my hair has
changed like do you notice a difference
in my hair like you see these breaky
little oh yeah I've had that forever I'm
falling like I'm understanding what
Alicia Keys is like protesting against
like as a woman who in the industry like
why do I always have to do my hair yeah
it's not that I have to I want to but
it's so annoying so like I'm trying to
iron less and my hair is all crinkly so
honestly these extensions couldn't have
come at a better time
for me personally I mean have you got
them in morning sin she's never in my
life to me put a piece in see if I can
are they clipping I also just yes I also
just posted a YouTube tutorial showing
how I put my extensions in if you're a
professional hair stylist you're
probably laughing at me but I've been
wearing I've been wearing extensions for
over six years on and off it works for
me I'm not balding my hair is not
falling out knock on wood so I'm doing
something right you know
you got these packages real tight I just
I don't want you to lose one hair okay I
can't leave you've never worn extension
I know okay there's like a lot of hair
in here how many pieces come a lot of
pieces and they come in two strips three
ships four strips holy so quite
mathematical I explained in my last
video at the link in my bio so I clip
them open and I got a section off I feel
like I'm gonna ruin my hair you have a
ponytail on you know do you know but
here use this actually I might have a
scrap no I don't okay hold on
alright so it's where you could hold
that up yeah take that and then clip
these clip here do you want help no your
hair might be a little bit darker than
the hair but I'll make your hair look a
little lighter ah okay let's see oh we
got it looks so good it's just that one
is the same length as your hair but your
hair looks so full and it does make your
hair look a little bit brighter do you
always want brighter hair or darker hair
I thought a while ago about like dyeing
my hair like black cuz I think that's
like so pretty how my hair does look
fuller and that's only one piece thanks
jack your uncle better it's really such
great hair at a relatively affordable
price for extensions you can curl them
you can iron them you can color them
which is what I've done with mine I've
toned them down a little bit so that
each my hair is like three different
colors so my extensions have to be three
different colors too so they can really
take a beating which is really nice for
affordable hair and they're made from
100% virgin remy hair and it's it's the
good stuff virgin hair it's very
suspicious anyways we have so much to
discuss today because obviously we're
gonna have you at the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast obviously but also we have to talk
about Game of Thrones of course I want
to talk about our weekends it's now day
three of no hum eights which as a
Passover Jew means no bread that hasn't
been leavened how's it going for you
okay it's so hard like I'm eating matzah
like first of all matzah is problematic
because it doesn't fill you up
whatsoever like no matter what you put
on it I put peanut butter I put butter
like nothing to it clogs you up like I
was even dumped in like a week
like it's so annoying cuz it's so like
coarse like I don't even know how to
describe
it's like you're eating like mortar like
it's so rough and it's really [ __ ]
annoying and then yesterday me Margo and
Ben went to an Easter party and then we
went to get dinner afterwards any went
to Jemma I was like great whatever I'll
get like a fish and like it was just so
hard not to just eat pasta pizza like
and I don't even move didn't have gone
to Jemma because that's it right there
that's Temptation Island today I don't
even normally like always eat pizza or
pasta when I'm like I didn't tell you
restaurant but I like to dip into the
bread basket and and have maybe a side
of bread you know - pizza something I
was starving when I left the restaurant
that's the worst feeling like rolling
out of a [ __ ] expensive dinner
starving yeah that's the rough stuff
yeah I've actually never eaten as much
amounts of as I have this weekend I
always use Passover like as an
opportunity to try and just be like good
and we're gonna be a go coach this
weekend so like we really need to like
get our bodies nice and tight yeah we
really do um but it's a struggle the
Passover struggle but that's how we
commemorate our ancestors and I went to
at least we can do I waited see on kita
grocery store and I got like all you
know Passover Manischewitz brand snacks
you not like your extensions or no way
to but like what am I putting in one
pair of extensions like I didn't like
I'll put them in for real okay I'll do
them for you for stagecoach okay like a
cake country you know I was looking back
on my Instagram yesterday like a
pictures from when I was in Mexico and
like in January of like a few months ago
I couldn't realize I think I peaked like
just for like the like in the I think
it'll be like the most beautiful I've
ever been in like the next five years
okay I didn't even realize it at the
time like even then to now like I'm a
totally different person and when I was
in Mexico I went to Mexico twice in
January like both times I was just out
here looking snatched just [ __ ] like
full hair skinny legs like something
happened to me I know it's but you
always think that and then in in a few
months you'll look at pictures of you
from Coachella you'll be like I was the
most perfect I've ever been so true I
was the most perpetrator honestly I miss
Coachella
so much well we're going back no don't
even matter no baby no idea like I can't
think about anything else it's like
people ok member means to go to camp and
it was like the months leading up to
Campbell you couldn't convince her to
Tamara surgery like you were so excited
then when you got home from camp it was
like you were actually like in
depression like yeah you couldn't like
waking up alone was so sad you used to
like waking up next to your sisters and
like that's how I feel about stagecoach
like I have plans for us
and I don't know if Lauren Elizabeth has
gotten her shake it's yeah but like if
she hasn't like it'll like really impact
my time I know it will
I've been talking to her like every day
and the fact that I haven't heard it's
no it's it's bad news I can't say it
again I'm in desperate need of some
artist passes and some parking passes
from anyone who works at golden boy sir
stagecoach or if you work in the
industry and like I'm pay for them just
like hit me up I really like need to UM
I made everyone come to stagecoach um
and I still haven't gotten them tickets
yet so rusty but then you know I feel
like been Zack and Zack like if they
couldn't get tickets they would still
have the best time like we're staying on
a golf course like they wouldn't be free
might actually prefer not how do I go to
the hole well they might actually
perfect oh we did haven't gotten their
tickets yet no that's what I'm saying
cuz like I'm trying to go like the back
trying to get some like artist passes
like worst-case scenario we'll just buy
VIP tickets okay um but yeah it's um
it's a struggle it's a struggle okay I
understand I'm so excited for ch but
what is so crazy is before we go to
stage coach I will be in the new
apartment you have so much today that's
when these are the bonus of three days
of my life
what's today today is a day for content
you're doing some fun patreon episodes
also last week I filmed an episode with
Ben about dating advice that really just
turned into like Ben and I reminiscing
on the good old days
honestly I was there to talk claudia
chiming and in the back every time that
said said of falsity said something
incorrect I was a fact-checker of the
episode and not only is it just a really
fun and funny episode because I - Ben is
but I also thought it was really
informative and we gave good advice from
a male and female perspective yeah Ben
gives good advice when it comes to
dating even though he has less dating
experience that made but he also gives
like sometimes his advice is a little
harsh
but sometimes it's what you need to hear
like we are in a bad situation
dating-wise like Ben is there to pull
you out of it but sometimes he's just
totally off like when he said that he
didn't think that's act like me yes so
true when Jagan's actually that he's a
hard guy to read it's like the only
thing it's like you would think he's
having a bad time but it turns out he's
having a great look you could tell me
like zach is so excited about something
I'm like to me I think he's driving it
like I have no idea that's really true
but when acting when we first met Zach
Jackie Ben Zach and I all went out for
like a business meeting we were working
together on something and we like we're
just trying to gauge whether or not like
Sakura Jackie and we got home and I was
like Ben like what do you think and he
told me he was like I don't think he
likes her and I was like so afraid to
tell you but
so the thing that you didn't because I
would have been so discouraged and I
probably wouldn't have turned out the
way that it did which is look at that
marriage eh okay are you ready for what
to get into the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
yeah I am yeah honestly it was a busy
weekend it was like the clock struck
noon on Friday and then a ton of news
broke yeah a ton of people broke up
first stop Adele and her husband Simon
are divorcing shocking shocking and so
sad like and I know ever if I hear the
joke it's gonna be a fire album one more
time like comment everybody take a seat
it's really crazy because like there are
just some people who like you feel like
it's over for them like Adele found her
match and like she's gonna have a happy
life and she's even said that she's like
I'm not ready music like there's nothing
sad in my life but Wow
like I really thought that like this guy
was it for her you know and she was so
heartbroken once before like to have
ever written the song someone like you
like you have to be in the worst state
of your life and she's been through so
much emotionally and you could just see
that in her music and I'm really shipped
to my core that Simon didn't end up
being the one for her you know they have
a kid together
I know like they actually were they
technically married or just together
they were married because they're
divorcing oh wow
and it's just so sad like I want nothing
but love for Adele even if it means that
it means no more music
you know ya know she's just like but you
know what kind of makes sense cuz she
was like seeing out and about a few
times this past few months with like
Jennifer Lawrence like getting drunk I'm
like she's obviously like in a bender
you know and good for her I would love
to be there for her down on her bender
like I could be so helpful I talked [ __ ]
about her acts I got her [ __ ] up cher
were the cool spots I buy her some drugs
you know yeah deleg needs to go to
Joshua Tree and just like do meth and I
feel like she'll come back with the
album of a century Kacey Musgraves said
she was on LSD when she broke a lot of
Golden Hour
so I feel like it's really good for the
musical creative side of the dough and
then be more than happy to go get the
shrooms by them drive her in an RV to
Joshua Tree and just take care of
business for her that's really sweet of
you you're a good friend that's just a
type of friend I am yeah I mean you you
know when you've been in a law what am i
doing I'm constantly bringing you
crystal meth that's just the kind of
friend I am yeah anyways I feel like we
haven't seen Adele and so long like and
now she's gonna like bubble back to the
surface with an album and a tour and you
know
he's in all of this and like I'm excited
but I was just excited for like this
quiet life for her because it felt like
that's what she wanted and to know that
someone doesn't have what they want
anymore
makes me sad that's so true it's like
she disappeared when she had everything
she wanted she had a very quiet life in
London like no press the media knows
news is good news
yeah but like for us and news is good
news for us you know I'm saying it's
like but then we get music yeah but it's
people out here making music even though
we could no one's making it like Adele
and maybe we really do need her I mean
now I think back to her most previous I
don't have songs like earth what's it
called earth I mean it is our planet we
need Adele we need a gel because the
song when we were young it's not only
like the greatest song like as a song
but it spoke to me like and it's not
even about love like she didn't really
write about anything like it's just
about memories it's just about that
feeling like you just look up one day
and like you're so old and like your
whole life passed you by I'm like I'm
only 24 but I feel like literally I miss
my entire life you know what I mean
and that song like spoke to me and then
and then when she gets raspy at the end
and she's like I'm getting oh that
mystery glues like I felt that in my
vagina yeah so you know what this isn't
that terrible of news for me
but for a doubt it's like that song when
she was married which was happy and it's
in her greatest what do you think is
Adele's best album 2125 the newest the
latest album what was a cult 20:27 no
addict oh no 25 she said she ate two
albums she is 21 25 she was 23 23 and me
she definitely knows I'm gonna hurt I'm
gonna go yes she definitely has three
albums that's for damn sure maybe she
has like 18 oh I guess she does that's
chasing pavements okay but just double
check from when she's a teen oh sorry
I'm looking in the stagecoach season all
I've been listening to the stagecoach
[ __ ] playlist okay remember I first
time you know Adele she has 21 25 and 19
19 19 was chasing pavements what was 21
was someone like you rollin in the deed
I was like her true it was Inc and 25
was water under the bridge when we were
young how I asked know is it yeah 25 yes
it is oh yes
if this is my last when I was in high
school you know that wasn't ever single
and she doesn't perform it on her tour
and like I don't know if people know
about it and it's something I've ever
done she not about when I was in high
school and like Adele was the [ __ ] when
I was 21 like when she did 20 21 it was
like someone like you rolling in the
deep' it was like the heyday of Adele
and like there were a lot of brave
people seeing it on the talent show and
like even me I think that my I think I'm
Aretha Franklin and even I would not
death rumor has it like singing Adele in
the talent show like who do you think
you are Rumour Has it's like not her
hardest
I'm just saying like comparing yourself
that's like would anyone ever get out
and sing Jennifer Hudson no no it's
saying key but when people seeing
Whitney Houston
it's like who the [ __ ] do you think you
are honestly Beyonce like I'll never you
know it's so mean alright that's that
later okay no it's it's brave season to
sing Whitney Houston Adele Jennifer
Hudson Mariah Carey yeah I mean new
Mariah Carey anyone could know but like
okay yeah the whistling yeah yeah or
like ariana grande but people do know
but her son know vocally challenging
no she just like laces in her with yes
or whatever okay I really wanna be able
to do the whistle like I don't know if
this is the place to start practicing
we just lost 30 subscribers okay
speaking more breakup news Danny
Amendola posts and elites rant bashing
Olivia Coco's Instagram theme okay to be
honest I think they have bunch of Danny
Amendola has a mental [ __ ] breakdown
on Instagram this weekend not once not
twice but thrice thrice and you know
what I'm going to the morning to its
Instagram and you have to read the whole
page you the whole caption it is so me
range worthy and grammatically incorrect
and as it is sometimes people will say
or do something either in jest or
whatever but it gives you a really big
like indication in to the type of person
they are and Danny Amendola says one
thing in here that made me like it
opened my eyes like I just got a little
glimpse of like he's mean okay I'm gonna
read the caption he posted a video of
live as her friends call quote I believe
there should be a boundary
bTW I think means between private life
in social media
Olivia believes in fishbowl lifestyle
this fundamental difference was huge in
our relationship if you're my real
friend you know I'm private my mother
brother father and nephew nots me Ches
are closest to me in this world and you
don't see one picture of them and that's
for their protection from those who
criticize and judge I believe in nailing
pictures frames on the inside of my
house to remind the ones I love that I
care sweet Olivia chooses and wants to
be noticed on the internet and in
Hollywood to make money which was hard
for me to understand but quickly had to
learn it's called business yeah look it
up sweetie
whereas the cost of Fame in this world
doesn't appeal to me I play ball for one
reason and that's respect the only
reason I'm writing this post is because
whether I liked it or not we live it in
the public eye some of it is amazing
I've met some of the nicest people from
all over the world and Olivia and I had
some amazing times together just like
any other loving relationship we fought
a lot of the time it was my fault I'm
sorry I think I should interpretive
dance to this I think so I think you
should interpretive dance to like the
next half because it gets crazy okay and
it's like okay tell me what I need you
to bring levity to the situation okay
let me go back to where I was a lot of
the time it was my fault because let's
be honest I can be an idiot okay now
it's time for the hard court but yep
she's [ __ ] up too and if you cross me
I'm a hard [ __ ] to deal with the
universe brought her and I together to
enjoy life love and learn we celebrated
that as often as we could and the sex
was [ __ ] crazy too
she gets so mad at me for not posting
her on social media but I think this
[ __ ] is sometimes fake sometimes toxic
but sometimes beautiful and I felt like
she had enough pictures online anyway
truth is I have a whole cell phone of
funny embarrassing sexy pics i G would
love to have however living a public
image isn't my choice it's something
I've learned to deal with reading all
these wild stories about her and I and
seeing Olivia with other men I just
wanted to personally clear the air out
here we've been on and off for a long
time and not together as of late not
sure what's in the future but the only
thing I care about is her happiness and
if that's Dancing with scrawny little
[ __ ] so be it
said so I'm happy too with that said
live my beautiful xgf Providence's
finest and bakers BAE pancakes carry on
IG
the beginning of the caption was sweet
talking about how he's like the only
thing that matters inside he prefers to
nail frames on the inside of his house
very sweet the middle is so [ __ ] rude
and evil and then the end is like nice
and sweet and concludes you Tori right
but it's like I feel like all inclusive
all this time we wanted to know like
what happened between Ali and Danny and
now that I know it's like don't tell me
you know this is horrible like okay so
she isn't influencer like she gets by by
people knowing about her life and just
like being a celebrity and that's
totally fine and totally normal
and it's like I hate when people like
I'm happy for you Danny Amendola that
you have the privilege to work half the
year and make so much money off of a
god-given talent that you definitely
work hard Apple it good for you but that
must be nice but also talking about I
didn't choose this life it's something
that I deal with like you're afflicted
with a disease like it's cancer you know
like it's something that I've learned to
deal with like no it's it's a privilege
and yeah I'm sure sometimes it can be
intrusive and it can take a toll on your
relationship but like all relationships
are hard you know I just thought it was
a kind of judgment starting for you
imagine if we weren't like Olivia makes
her money by like you know spreading her
legs that's basically what he said it's
like so not true it's like she's out
here creating premium content being a
fashion influencer I'm he's doing it
better than anyone else yeah and I just
have something influenced a derogatory
thing to say like good for you that you
would make a living like a very very
handsome living doing that right the
companies don't have to work in
different ways and this is the world
that we live in this is a chat we live
in and you know what you can either
evolve or die agreed oh my god totally
you know Charles who said survival of
the fittest
Darwin him you know you can evolve where
you can get left behind is really what
it is but Charles Darwin said so I just
thought this was not cool justice for
Olivia and now I [ __ ] ship her and
Zed because I saw the video of them
dancing and apparently he's tall and so
I'm here for it I don't know if I
necessarily ship her and said I'm more
so ship her with like a Calvin Harris
okay but like this is one step closer to
Cap'n Harris my but these days these
days
Zed is making more music than common
Harris I'm totally relevant
aesthetically os ethically okay sure but
like will exhibit the haircut you know
I'm fine with said like he's like his
homeboy can get it home we can def most
certainly got it and I think Danny's
just said that she's moving on of course
and it's like we also saw those pictures
of him in Miami like oh please and all
sound sit down
also like you don't want a thirst on
Instagram but literally this
the definition of thirst like boiling it
up every article picking up your thing
deleting it like this is thirsty this is
this the level of thirst on this
Instagram post is more than Olivia's
entire Instagram to mine right and like
what Olivia did with her relationship
with Danny and posting on Instagram she
was giving all of us like just the taste
to satisfy us just what we needed and
without revealing too much and we all
knew like I know who Danny Amendola was
before Olivia culpo not I please she's
an amazing things for his career for his
brand for his PR and also for the
Patriots cuz like I'm out of here
shipping the Patriots but like the Lions
now some Lions Gronk retired honestly
I'm over the painter falling apart yeah
without Danny because of Olivia because
everything she touches she's Queen Midas
everything she touches turns to gold
including her next relationship and I
hope it's a I hope it's wonderful for
her me too I don't know if legs ed is
like gonna be the Romeo to her Juliet
but let's hope but it's something and if
someone to dance with that comes tellin
sometimes that's really all you need
Oh sometimes you're not there with your
sister even though she's always with her
sister and also she isn't Anthony Jess
uh-huh and she's an incredible aunt and
she's always posting her nephew you know
speechiess on Instagram it doesn't shock
me that like the universe brought us
with like together with Olivia culpo
like because we admired her for so long
from afar and like we loved that she
loved her sisters and she loves country
music and she played the cello in
addition to being like the most
beautiful girl ever she's like smart and
like loves her family and plays a cello
and obviously we like we're obsessed her
and but like the universe really brought
us like we've like come to know and love
Olivia COPO just like in a natural way
because the universe demanded it of us
like yeah they brought us together at
the porta-potties our Coachella we met
Danny Amendola meet a bad feeling about
him back then he was running home to go
you know celebrate then it's like I'm
the CMA red-carpet look we were just
gravitated towards her like she has
sisters we have sister she has a nephew
we have a nephew like I just I can't she
has a watch we have a watch right like I
just can't thank the gods enough the 709
new
for like bringing us together towards
let me a comb because there's like
certain people in this world that we
were meant to know and love and like
she's one of them yeah and defend yeah a
totally I just I'm just glad she's in
the head but I'm good for him for
putting her in the headlines that's
where she deserves to be on create a
list so thanks and she needs to get used
to talk about Olivia Coco it's just his
win for us she needs to get to dating
she's like one of those other people
that we like me to set up a building
website and wear
we're setting up Matt Hardy and Olivia
culpo someone who desperately needs to
be set up I asked because I think she
can find the great love of her life
while also increasing her star like in
Hollywood like if she like when she was
dating Nick Jonas like that did great
things for her I think like I really
could see her with like with with an
actor you know but where does she live
where she's all over a businessman bo I
think the businessman but one who can
work remotely with her from the private
jet and maybe someone who like works
business in her industry so he
understands like why she's doing what
she's doing which clearly Danny was not
in tune with what's necessary yeah which
is always a shame when that happens
always a shame when that happens it's
just hate to see it she just needs
someone to like you know fly around the
world with her like take care of her you
know eat meals with her on the go you
know she means someone who uses daily
harvest that's what I was trying to say
and I'm so glad that you brought me to
that you know final resting point are
you ready I'm ready tell me what you
love daily harvest I like it too TLE
harvest delivers carefully source chef
crafted smoothies savory bowls overnight
oats and more built on fruits and
vegetables everything stays fresh in
your freezer until you're ready to eat
it
you can choose from more than 50
nourishing options for any time of day
ready to bone smoothies savory harvest
bowls soups and more each single serving
cup takes one step to prepare add water
or milk to a smoothie or heat up a
harvest ball go to dark daily - harvest
calm and enter promo code toast to get
three cups free in your first box that's
a promo code toast at daily harvest
daily - harvest calm excuse me you get
free three daily harvest cups at daily -
harvest calm daily - harvest calm for
three free daily harvest cups using code
toast
I love daily harvest it's really gotten
me through like being a woman on the go
and not especially during your move
especially during my move and especially
while I didn't know how to cook yeah
yeah okay are you ready for the next
story oh so you'll I think you're like a
past that stage now it's like you're a
woman who knows how to cook well on
Friday night for our first Seder
I made my the veggies that were promised
and I was so nervous because I didn't
know if they were gonna cook properly
the oven was being weird and like they
weren't looking like crispy and then I
had to apologize to everyone before
dinner started because I didn't think
they came out well you were being like
really self-conscious about it would you
Sofitel conscious fast forward ten
minutes later the bowl was empty clean
everyone loved
vegetables and if they didn't love the
vegetables they at least pretended to
you because they're such good siblings
and I loved them and they gave them off
to Theo I just don't eat vegetables you
don't eat vegetables but I did I would
have liked that Zach ate so many
vegetables so nice it was so nice Ben
said he liked them Olivia who's Colin a
very just very judgmental so it was
really good success I definitely felt
really encouraged and I look forward to
any more for you yeah okay next up Kanye
West's Easter Sunday service takes over
Coachella as promised Kanye West brought
his Sunday service to Coachella on
Easter morning as dozens of musicians
singers and dancers performed a set of
spiritual songs covers and songs by the
rapper himself including a new one
called water for an audience of
thousands from a hilltop on the festival
grounds in Indio California it looked so
cool and I was trying to watch the live
stream but like with that tiny little
circle they lost me and I like saw Kim's
ass and then I left it was really
annoying that circle but I guess it was
kind I don't know I can't imagine like
what the rationale was me I don't even
want to purport to know no but I saw
Instagram stories of people who were
there and like a just man looked yeah it
looked like so fun so cool it looked so
hot and I saw a chance of rapper and
Kanye like wearing sweats and I was like
oh my god they must be dying up there
like not only are they working jumping
moving singing dancing but like also
wearing thick sweatshirt and sweatpants
yes but I feel like they were really
just having like the time of their lives
especially for so many of the people
like the backup singers and dancers like
they weren't performing a hotel ax the
crowd was massive and I think really
like they were they were transported and
it's so crazy like I watched pretty much
the whole thing once I realized it was
on like they took me to church like
Iowans we church on Easter Sunday and
I'm a big Jew so good for that people
were up in arms about the pricing of
merch I mean it's a one-time experience
and know he's gonna get knocked off so
many times as men as well make as much
money as he can in the beginning right
and it's like he knows that people are
gonna pay that amount so it's like we're
the suckers who will out who created
this monster but it's like the people
who go to Coachella are spending like
two thousand dollars like on the ticket
on transportation like on the house like
please another $100 sweatshirt like
they'll be fine yeah I didn't think that
was a degree just especially knowing
that they're gonna sell out and then
they're gonna go on eBay for even more
money and someone's gonna spend that
much and it's like he could have charged
on right and like then he's gonna get
knocked off by literally every single
person on acetate right so you know what
I'm fine with it I'm kind of the two
didn't bother me whole family was there
Kylie and Travis were there Chris was
there Khloe was there
Courtney was there and Kim is there kids
didn't brought the kids up for like a
second Mason saying poop did he scoop
and he botched it oh he's done what his
piece is dug up the joint
oh that's Kanye so yeah but the
beginning of it is lift yourself up off
your feet which is very you know churchy
yeah and then it go and then it just
goes into I hope you do this on tour
well that when Zach came on the morning
toast and he is world-renowned called
insert aficionado and the biggest Kanye
fan that I know he we were just talking
about they had started posting the
services on Instagram and he was like I
think Kanye's gonna do a church tour and
he's gonna become like do he's gonna
become like Charles ball yeah and at the
time I was like I didn't see it but
literally we were watching yesterday he
was like I call this I was like he did
that would be so cool I would totally go
to that I mean she'd do it in like big
auditoriums like not at MSG you know or
make em take up I don't know wherever as
many people can go to church as possible
ya know I would totally go and a lot of
his songs like an avid and now like
looking back the ultra light beam is
like rap but then the chorus is all like
gospel yeah it's been coming for a while
I like that it was it was really
enjoyable to watch and it's like all
these you know Coachella thirst monsters
like they they went to church and and
you know what is good for Kanye for like
bringing out their religiosity but oh
like left their families on Passover on
Easter and good uncon you for bringing
some good family values to Coachella
which is otherwise a bottomless pit of
sadness ya know I am so I'm so here for
it and like I wish that we were there
that weekend that he was there because I
would have woken up and gone to it and
then left didn't came back like I would
have gone to that yeah of course you
know and the kids were just right there
he didn't even do it on a stage he just
did it on a hill if he's like he'll just
there I guess so
if you build it they will come and he
built it and look what they came
exciting that looks really cool okay
more Coachella
cameos Mary Morris Mary Morris and
Justin Bieber makes first stage
appearance in two years at Ariana
Grande's Coachella set ariana grande
knows how to make up for a lost
opportunity after facing near-disastrous
sound issues during Nicki Minaj's
because it wasn't to say it wasn't as
the show went on it was fine after a
performance that was relatively similar
to weekend one grande took a pause
between break free and her pen
to meet track no tears left to cry to
bring out Justin Bieber he said innocent
come twice I guess if it was as similar
as it was the week before then yeah I
don't know I really wish I watched it on
livestream but like Game of Thrones was
on and I'm sorry dude she said I wasn't
going to bring out any yes tonight but
my friend Justin Bieber came all the way
out and he went on stage and he also
said that an album is coming soon
did they sing anything he sang um sorry
oh this ended together yeah so they have
the same manager it's gonna run huh and
I just wonder like what's this
orchestrated by him are they actually
friends like they're always like like
when when she when she came out with
thank you next alesis and god forbid
something happens at least his song is a
smash one did like the day came out
Justin like I would have been hurt from
it in like years went on Twitter I was
like Lisa and he quoted that light he's
like that's funny
like they're always supporting one
another made don't know if there's like
an actual friendship there or they just
have the same manager and they're using
like one when Justin's hi he brings up
Ariana when Ariana's how he brings up
Justin I think it's both and I think
also Ariana's friends with everyone she
is like really good relationships with a
lot of people like all the people who
performed at one love Manchester all the
teacher who came onstage last week this
week she's so close with Miley like I
feel like everyone really loves her and
she doesn't like have beef that's not
her thing no she doesn't a beef with
girls yes guys like a normal person
right interesting interesting speaking
of her friends you're not caught up on
dynasty but this week's episode was
actually like not enjoyable because it's
like I'm just not feeling the pot lines
but the last three minutes like I was on
the floor
I love Liz Gillies so much well now we
have a double dose of Liz Gillies why
double okay spoiler alert if you're no
no I don't wanna know oh it's sorry I
were talking with something else no so
okay she was an evil twin I don't want
to know okay I'm not telling you anyways
catch up I'm dying to see okay it's just
we are sleeping on it I know I think my
faith I'm 100% sleeping on it I just
have such a hard time like feeling
motivated to keep up on shows that
aren't real like reality shows and then
we don't recap here I know
well dynasty and Game of Thrones are the
only scripted shows that I watch and
some Riverdale when I'm like I have a
lot of time but did you know veep was
back no
because kind of fell off the deep wagon
no I was fully on it but then they took
up they announced it it was the last
season and Julia Louie Dreyfus was
diagnosed with breast cancer so they
like took some time off and then they
were gonna like release the final season
and I just when I was watching Game of
Thrones I'm saying I got to HBO like a
couple minutes early and they were
showing commercials and they were like
next week's veep I was what that
something and I just I need to catch up
and I'll just like binge on an airplane
it's a really enjoyable catch-up it is
it's so funny it's so funny it's
literally the best show on TV and what's
so great about it is that it's all about
politics without ever once being
political right such a nice reprieve you
still I mean I don't know where they're
right now but you still don't know if
Selina Meyer is a Democrat or an
independent and it doesn't matter and
then I was just talking about like
issues like so like weirdly like oh well
you know like yes so Mila buster yeah
yeah yeah it's really just a fantastic
show I like it so much totally okay
fifth and final story there's been a lot
of we haven't talked about the royal
family in a while there's been a lot of
drama surrounding them
Megan like it looks like she's due to
give birth any day now her models in
town and like people were like looking
at how the schedules and they think they
figure out I think it's gonna happen
like this in the next week oh wow also
then I also like saw some drama that
Harry and Megan might be moving to
Africa because the palace wants me as
far away as possible says you know the
tea so they didn't need like another
cottage on the pallets like a little far
away which was apparently a big deal and
what the tea supers are saying like no
but Melanie Bromley is saying every time
they move is that they're just doing it
today it's hour away from the palace cuz
the palace doesn't want me near them and
they don't want me near the palace and
they don't know if it's just like 100
percent fabrications of the truth or
just like so legit well why would they
want to be away from the palace me
because she think she's better than
everyone that's what this yeah it's a
narrative
she doesn't want to be under Queenie
vibes his thumb she doesn't want to be
under Queenie bags of some under Kate's
um because she's always second to Kate
like see things now like the world
revolves around her even though like
there's two people that revolves around
more than her yeah and that's Kate and
the Queen she's revolving around the
world truly she met it I wouldn't not be
surprised it's like the next revolve in
the Hamptons like they got Megan Marco -
oh I would not be surprised at all like
they got Kim that's harder arguably ya
know and I feel like something is it's
definitely crazy over there ya know this
all can't be faked but it all can't be
real agree and even when they were
saying [ __ ] about
like some of it was true look she was
cheating and like she was doing all that
anyway this is a marriage was bad and ya
know so they were right they just took
it to it like another level by like
killing her and stuff but they weren't a
hundred percent lot using the palace
killed her the media oh yeah yeah yeah
the media like they took it too far with
their stories because they because they
were like too obsessed with her right
but like the basis of those rumors
wasn't completely false no not at all so
there's something here yeah and like
when they say you know where there's
smoke there's fire and I don't think
they just like I think there are some
crazy tabloids who are on crazy stories
but like when it's on like E News and
it's in every pretty much every
publication like there has to be some
marriage the couple of Star Magazine
saying that both Reese Witherspoon and
Jennifer Aniston are pregnant like
that's just not true right they have
literally been saying that like or that
kendall Jenner and Travis Scott or have
not yeah or they all say on that Kanye
and camera like divorce for the last
three years right but it's not true the
accountability they never sure rebuttal
no it's so annoying like if you go to
the airport and look at the magazine
covers it's [ __ ] world in shambles
right so I wouldn't believe those
stories but like you know there's
certain like page six like they and like
British media is like not as tabloid II
I think as America like America mania
they have absolutely no regard for the
truth like they just couldn't care less
if something's true or not whereas I
think there's a little bit more
accountability in British media like the
son the Daily Mail like say what you
want about the Danny I think it might be
the exact like I think it might be the
opposite I don't know I'm not well
barracks is if you think about the Daily
Mail like Britain British people I
consider the Daily Mail to be absolute
trash like tabloid yeah and trust it's
true but it but it is true like and it's
just like it's a little like edgy in the
way that they were think sometimes but
for the most part I don't consider it to
be like a crazy like fable okay magazine
yeah this is just some of the thing
about anyways I'm excited for her to
have her better and I think I feel like
if they really do move to Africa that'll
maybe we're like a dude arm up some of
these rumors but is there a palace in
Africa for them I don't know yeah I'm
sure I think I don't know that's not
under British jurisdiction like it's not
no no it used to be it's not like Wales
you know yeah we'll see it depends where
a knife we're gonna move to who knows
it'll be it'll be exciting this is just
such a wild time like if you're from
Africa
why are you right it's a while it's a
crazy time to just like be alive it's a
crazy time to be mega marker and it's
like I can blame at your mother who got
pregnant like so quickly she hasn't even
been married for a year no it's like it
makes you think you know oh girls would
get pregnant so quickly like when they
marry up makes you think that's all I'm
gonna say I don't know I'm not thinking
I'm just like cool good for her do you
think she knows that what people are
saying about her cuz like when we were
that like you have an Instagram it on
himself actually they made an Instagram
and like I saw an article in Cosmo here
it's 37 clues by Megan Markel's actually
the one running the Instagram for house
Kensington but Instagram comments aren't
a reflection of what people are saying
about her so I hope she's not reading
that it's like I hope she's reading it
just like all the headlights I hope
she's like a Google Alert for herself
then that's what people are saying about
she definitely does in but she might
have like a press secretary whose job it
is to like briefing on what Americans
think about her right and then like
she'll go and like act accordingly maybe
like right like to undo some of the
rumors right
no but there's some truth here I refuse
to believe that all of this is just
pulled out of Melanie Bromley's ass a
hundred percent there's some truth makes
a good it really it makes you think it's
crazy I still can't believe it like that
Megan Markel is the princess and do you
think the baby's gonna be born in Africa
no I mean I don't know but it seems like
they're in London London and she's at
the point now where she can't travel
Lauren Burnham is in Bermuda I'm like I
thought she was like ready to go but
she's traveling so she must be like
still like six months she looked huge
ship twins I don't know but she yet she
doesn't really big belly yet so you
would think that she's like nine months
but she's traveling so she's obviously
not know and it's April they'll be like
their last trip yeah when when you have
to stop traveling I don't know anything
about anything so I'm not gonna talk
about it I'm really enjoying watching
her like pregnant so you follow baby
line day of course you I just like I
love them so much like I'm so happy for
them like they proved all the haters
wrong like I just and like he looks like
weirdly he's gonna be like such a good
like goofy dad she is just like
beautiful like more radiant than ever
and like I just like sometimes when like
people like document their lives on
social media I'm like they have big life
change it's like pregnancy like I think
they're annoying but like there's
something about Lauren Burnham she's
just doing it in like such a nice
organic way like I really like her I
really like her too and I really like
them I'm I'm not following people and I
click you are but
I'm happy that you're happy you're
missing out on some premium content well
no I soloed them so I feel like I'm
getting all the updates you know I'm
kidding you're totally I was he on
anything maybe stop for now but I just I
really like them okay you want to talk
drones of course I want to talk cones
okay
nothing happened is the second episode
out of six and you know what's make
anything and this is gonna be like
fraught with spoilers for sure so like
if you haven't watched go watch the fact
that we even have to say that is so
stupid the thing is is that this up at
this season is six episodes and the
first two were nothing last season was
eight episodes I really feel like they
could have done the entire season last
season in like 11 episodes Oh probably
but they just wanted to stretch it out
they wanted to show check out also last
season I can't say the word stretch
without thinking with an outstretched
arm what's that oh my god you can't the
Seder of course thousand times a night
and our Lord with an outstretched arm
seen just from Egypt it's like a
thousand times I say it yeah with an
outstretched arm it's like it's not even
have arms he has outstretched arms right
he's a good shape no but last season was
all about people coming together the war
in the realm and then this season's
really about like the war against adead
so I'm glad to have it broken up and
like I've said before like I don't want
this show to end so when something when
nothing happens in an episode like I'm
not that sad because I'm not rushing for
it to be over
you know actually not at all and
especially because now I'm watching we
only have four more episodes season of
the greatest show of our time I'm
watching season a but I'm also watching
from the beginning I'm up on season six
meet in the middle of season six so I'm
kind of happy like nothing's happening
cuz I really want to catch up completely
before next week which I think I well
with the stagecoach flights I just think
I'll be in really good shape yeah so
nothing like really like no parts moving
I'm not actually upset about
agreed that space episode was so
enjoyable it felt like a finale like
everyone's saying their goodbyes
everyone tying up loose ends
characters coming together who like
haven't seen each other a while but who
had like connections before you know
what they're doing it's like intentional
they're like making us like again follow
these characters like know more about
them on a deeper level like that smile
I'm Brienne of Tarth space when she got
knighted was so sweet
but so sad because she is for sure gonna
die they wouldn't make us love someone
so much unless they were gonna die there
was no and I loved more from last
night's episode than tormund fortunately
we'll be dying
then was dying laughing sweet he's
already so big because he sucked on the
teat of a giant's wife because he did
I thought it was his baby was so funny
and he gets too rigid he's a big girl
yeah he was being so funny which makes
me sex it doesn't mean good things and
when they were in that room while
sitting around the fire Jamie torment
projects they're gonna drag sir Davos
terian the only person that was missing
was Sir Bronn of the Blackwater because
he has history he's boys with all of
those people and he needs to get into
town Welsh I know he's there to kill I
don't think he's gonna do it I don't
think he's gonna kill Jenny it's like no
I'm watching back and like bran was such
a good friend to such a good friend and
he's all about the money but he's also
about that he's loyal and he's greedy he
accepted that wife in that house in that
castle so he wouldn't be the champion
for Tyrion when he was on trial for for
Joffrey's murder but he was smart to do
that he couldn't beat the mountain ya
know even Oberyn who actually Oberyn
could beat the mountain but he couldn't
beat himself and he got caught in he
didn't anybody stop his own head you
know when they were all sitting around
the fire was so cute and then like pod
Podrick is it's just so interesting now
watching Season eight but also coming
from watching the entire seasons like
who survived and like why they survived
it said you thought like the world
couldn't go on without Ned Stark or Robb
Stark in like my world was in shambles
like now I don't even care about them
but if you would have asked me about
Podrick I would have been like
who right now it's like I love projects
so much he like got a hair do he gained
a little bit of weight like looking more
like masculine and I just I love project
when he's saying that song with his
beautiful voice and then the song in the
credits was a song that Podrick was
singing like I just loved it I loved it
I'm having humanitarian are back
together because he was a good lad and
you know that Patrick has a big wiener
oh no which is not necessarily been
wiener but he knows all the women in the
brothel wouldn't accept payment from him
because now's like ooh if Patrick lives
who does he end up with now we have to
start making couples and having the
speaking of couples Maria the audacity
the audacity for us to have to watch our
little sister are you shocked
get thought was so not cool I saw her
tits and her ass yes for like one second
which on the side of it and then she
pulled underpants I started to show you
like I felt so uncomfortable like she's
a beautiful girl but like I grew up with
Arya like I know her she's literally
snitch like it was horrifying okay but
here's the thing first of all how this
shows been going on for seven seasons
that's
least seven years or eight seasons now
that's at least ten and she started with
you okay so she's 18 she it's I know so
we're watching her murder everyone see
murder be murdered etc and we can watch
her have sex no I'm sorry no it was
shocking to me but when you think about
it it's like this is fine I'd like to
get an a John Gendry but other than that
dream I was so hot I was happy for her
and like I know that she really liked
was in love with him and watching it
back like they really had that
connection I was actually a year ago I
was shipping Gendry and Santa but that
was before I realized that Orias in love
with Kendra Kendra is so hot Kendra so
hot I love his buzz cut just like out
here in the mining fields like welding
[ __ ] but why did she look so sad like
the morning after I don't know it's like
they're gonna die yeah and she loves him
so much maybe I'll be in heaven together
like why wasn't she like I have a
question cuddled up who was more I guess
who was a better claim to the throne
Gendry or Daenerys no or John they
technically have the same one cuz it's
like John is a Targaryen yeah so it's
like when the Targaryen is were in
charge John would be the heir last we
heard it's the Baratheon so like
technically Gendry um kendra has a claim
to the throne is it better or worse I
think it's worse because Robert
Baratheon is known as the usurper so it
depends what kind of world but it's like
who are we fighting for the house
Baratheon our House Targaryen and Danny
is really pissing me oh my god no I'm
I'm I'm here for Danny all the way you
know the fact that she literally refuses
to acknowledge the fact that her dad was
a [ __ ] monster necessary Oh Pat know
what she's out here being mad at Jaime
like Jaime saved lives she of course
she's mad and she's a she's so I agree
she just like demands everyone's respect
without ever having once earned it like
it's so annoying she knows where she is
she brought her whole army her dragons
etc up to Shitsville in the north
because you know what ok everyone thinks
it's like oh this is Winterfell spite no
let's say that though it's the world's
fight so yet it just being the human
being that she is bringing army she had
to I'm sorry I'm not grateful
oh you should be grateful no I am I am
but she's just really starting to piss
me off no I last week everyone was
turning on her and it was really
frustrating to me and also like yeah
maybe she's like a little bit you know
thrown a little - focus focus sometimes
but she always does read herself back in
sometimes she is on the wrong side when
she was getting really mad at Aryan but
then she like she really takes the
advice of her advisers and I think
that's so important she's not a perfect
person and when it comes to John like
and the Iron Throne I like I really wish
they kind of finish their conversation
oh you know um cuz I really was hoping
he was gonna say that he doesn't want
the Iron Throne um which I feel like he
wouldn't like Ned Stark didn't want it
like there are some people who are just
like too humble and too honorable to
take such a job and maybe she didn't
have like the perfect reaction but
imagine like your whole life thinking
you're the only Targaryen left on this
earth and not only do you find out that
there's another one it's a man and maybe
it goes against everything that you've
been working so hard for like you
remember those years in marine where she
legit ate [ __ ] yeah I think that wasn't
for nothing no I I I hear you I hear you
but I'm just like I'm really turning on
her like and and I just I know everyone
apparently Sciences the smartest girl in
the world now I'm not even team Sansa
but but here's how we can solve the
problems of the north I understand they
want to be free got it if Danny is queen
and John is king and then John has like
this relationship with the north maybe
we can all get along right but that's
not like a permanent solution because
they'll die and like sound sad like she
wants the like forever she wants they
don't want to bow bend the knee anymore
like she they want them to be a free
people forever until like John just
temporarily being King like doesn't help
that's true because nothing's forever
but it's the Seven Kingdoms you're just
gonna split him up
I know I know but I'm just like really
like every time Daenerys is on screen
like I want to slap her in the face
she's bothering me so much the
entitlement where she just rolls into a
place where nobody knows her and all
they know is her crazy [ __ ] dad and
being outraged when like every single
person doesn't immediately bend the knee
and kiss her ass like get real [ __ ] I
don't think she's outraged I think she
expects something it doesn't happen
she's patient she proves herself it
happens whatever she's always proving
herself she took her [ __ ] dragon
beyond the wall and lost such a lost a
son even though that bothers me so much
because they did all of that for [ __ ]
Cersei like who nothing the mcniel not
only did they waste time they lost a
dragon
they lost men all for Cersei even if she
brought her army it wouldn't have been
worth it they should have just ignored
the [ __ ] I loved a couple unsullied
Round four honestly burn them all burn
everyone in King's Landing is a [ __ ]
I loved okay you know it's um the
episode without Cersei like she's so
nobody died that's why it was so
enjoyable she's so evil and it's like
they really in a weird way there have
been what like a hundred characters on
Game of Thrones and they've really
whittled it down to like the top 20 like
I just love everyone so much except for
Cersei like the ones that they decided
like torment I didn't even give a [ __ ]
about it when he was a wildling but now
he's truly like my best friend
I love the Hound too and it's like Arya
nieces have some respect no like all the
Starks need to get their [ __ ] together
like and start like stuffing in their
[ __ ] don't stink like everyone's equal
now no one like you know who doesn't
care about Lordships and hierarchy is
the [ __ ] White Walkers right you know
right we're all equals six feet below
right also song sends the yeah because I
was wondering who dastan to end up with
oh my god why would you think she ends
up with Theon oh my god that didn't even
cross right how would they have children
right I have to tell you something like
and this goes against everything we
believe like I love Theon so much like
when he was like he could go home and he
was like no I'm gonna go fight for
Winterfell it's like he made such a big
mistake when he was a kid but like he's
in so many miss he's an idiotic teenager
I'm like that period where he killed Sir
Roderick and he took over when two
felony kill the farmers boys like was
horrible and it was awful like in
hindsight like it's so not important and
like he learned his lesson and he
learned it in such a hard way and he
paid for his crimes oh my god in Spain
in spades and I just love him so much in
like I think like I think he deserves a
second chance
no he has his second chance and if he
ends up with some so like that's that
surprise that's disgusting like he
doesn't like I just they're brother and
sister wait no they can't either the
berliner they're not they were raised
together but they were never raised his
brother and sister opted no would you
marry your adopted brother he wasn't
adopted yes he was no he wasn't he
essentially was held against his will
no he wasn't he was a captor now they're
not related but it's still weird I mean
who else would you have her with any ID
of someone hi I guess I forgot that
we're like trying to ship everyone off
yeah and also the fact that they all
really believe that they're gonna die
makes me think that they're not because
usually when they go into battle and
they're like we got this Stannis
Baratheon it's like yeah you have
nothing so I guess okay so Sansa and
Theon that's like so weird
Arion Gendry and you know what in the
first
episode 1 Robert what about what about
Tyrion in the first episode Robert
Baratheon says to Ned Stark like I have
a son you have a daughter and let's
combine our houses and and you thought
it was sunset and Joffrey but it's
really arean Gendry oh that's cute
really cute Tyrion
yeah or Tyrion and Sansa I still ship it
me Jesus you're [ __ ] dumb to realize
he was the best thing I've ever happened
to her oh my god saved her [ __ ] life
saved your life what a catch smartphone
the guy in town where just got in town I
loved Tyrion totally but I have a
question about Brienne of Tarth enlike
maybe it's stupid like obviously tormund
loves her and they're both Giants and
they're perfect for each other but like
I think Jamie loves her I think Jamie
loves her I think she loves him and but
I don't think she's ever dealt with
these sorts of feelings before like this
has never been an issue for like someone
likes her and she likes them or she
likes anyone right so it's like she's
trying to figure out I want to set up
one of the boys right so she's trying to
figure out what all these feelings even
mean
I think Jamie Lannister will be one of
the first people to die me too because
at the end of the day he's really the
least important and like integral to the
storyline but but if torment umbria and
like don't hook up before one of them
dies like I'm gonna be free and doesn't
get some ass like I'll be sad for her no
sane she deserves it she deserves
everything I'll just like I will never
forget Gendry and are ya just like
[ __ ] like it was horrible no and I
thought it would be he would like be
like no no and then maybe would happen
later but it was nope is happening right
that's in there
you wouldn't think he would necessarily
be attracted to her like she pretended
to be a boy for like the first few years
right and then like became like his
actual little sister like it's weird
it's weird but it's love the heart wants
what it wants
heart what a deaf girl trying to get
soup with like the burnt face she was so
Shireen oh my god she was so key and
then Gilly who looks so different
yeah what what what is it was what
happened to her her face looks
differently she had work done I don't
know I could literally couldn't be my
thing right I'm like who is that but
she's such a new response yes he's being
great she's just like the mom of
Winterfell cuz me yeah we don't there no
one else there is a mother right and
that girl was really cute Lyanna Mormont
like being a savage and I'm so glad we
got to see Lyanna Mormont and talking to
Jordan because we've all known that like
she's the head of his house and they got
to come together and then say I'm giving
Jordan to commanda it just all came to a
really tight
every loose end so that like when people
die like there was nothing left unsaid
and like we figured it out because for
some people like Ben was like why is
there Torah related to that girl you
know it's confusing and what I've
started to do which I can't believe I
wasn't doing for the past ten years is
watching with subtitles it's so helpful
cuz they say Mormont and it's like did
he just say mama like you don't know
what he says but you see more mountain
you're like oh that's Jorah like it
really I highly recommend everyone
watching with subtitles interesting I I
feel as though I understand pretty much
most of it no I'm I'm just I'm loving it
and like every Sunday that comes from
sad and dry it well every when I was
with Ben and Marco last and they're
freaking out cuz we're gonna be at
stagecoach next Sunday and they're gonna
be on the red-eye home on the flight and
I'm like oh that sucks but then I
realize we're staying so we could watch
at home yeah you know we'll come home
from sending it I don't want to watch
like buzz I watch it I Madison will be
fine I'll stay off my phone yeah I mean
the memes are so funny like the game of
Thrones the people who watch Game of
Thrones are unique in the sense that
like it's really like smart people watch
and the tweets that go viral are so
funny like for the first thing I do when
the episodes over is that constant I go
to hashtag Game of Thrones on Twitter
and there's such funny stuff it's really
good celebr and the torture no but he's
at least like moving the needle and he
forgave Jamie I guess last night's
episode did confirm that the the night
king was out here looking for brand I
didn't I still I need her watch season
I'm on season six and I feel like that's
what that's when bran is in that tree
and I'll understand more of like what
brands up to yeah um the night king is
looking for a brand they have to kill
the night king how do you kill the night
king I think you can kill him the same
way you kill I mean I don't think so he
can walk through fire oh but can he be
killed by dragon fire I don't know if
he's able to be killed by wherever my
and the dragons gonna battle yeah they
have to yeah I mean it's just a silly
that'd just be burning my knees if they
put the dragon on top of the wall like
and just [ __ ] breathed like the thing
is over no but the night king could
throw up a spike okay whatever that's
how he died the first time and there is
no wall anymore that is so crazy wonder
say like prop him up on some Castle
start breathing and that gets like 90%
of the job done and if they hadn't
brought a dragon over the wall because
of Cersei how the [ __ ] would they have
ever gotten over the wall the wall was
legit all this time when Cersei was like
the walls stood there for a thousand
years ago if the wall would have
protected them yeah they they
brought the battle to themselves yeah
John just always talking about it he
made it happen yeah
self-fulfilling prophecy everyone's
looking good though everyone's getting
nice and tight for for battle it's like
they've been on new they've definitely
been on you have you been on him yes I'm
always hunting me - no I'm not looking
nice and tight right now but I'm trying
sticking to a weight-loss plan can be
hard especially when you don't know how
to handle the thoughts and obstacles
that hold you back from making progress
most people who lose weight gain it all
back here here why because most weight
loss plans tell you to do what to do
while you're on the plan not after but
with noon you'll lose the guilt and
learn how to develop a new relationship
with food different results call for a
different approach learn don't diet
build new better habits for you
recognize and change habits that are
blocking your current success you get a
goal specialist it's a behavior change
professional nutrition expert and
fitness trainer all-in-one and you also
get a community that's there for you
just like the toasters you get group
discussions with fellow new members to
keep you encouraged it takes to acne out
of food tracking with one of the biggest
food databases available you track your
meal habits visualize portion sizes and
see caloric density at a glance numa's
designed for results its output the old
habits and in with the new sign up for
your trial today at noon and oom comm
slash toast what do you have to lose a
meet a lot apparently visit noon calm
slash toast to start your trial today
that's Noom dot-com slash toast start
losing weight for good that's really
sure like the hardest thing like people
say the hardest thing is losing weight
no the hardest thing is keeping it yeah
so it's actually helpful to have
something like that I've been on noon
for like a month
and I've not been great with it but but
at least it keeps you accountable it was
like the Mellencamp of ABS Oh totally um
okay I think that's all the Thrones talk
for today
you must watch Keeping Up with the
Kardashians Kourtney Kardashian is a
certified animal I'll watch it today and
then we'll do banner pump rules and
Kardashian's tomorrow yes okay so this
week is the busiest week of my life uh
we have episodes Monday Tuesday
Wednesday for why you're moving oh no no
no we're starting the move at at noon
okay so just be like uh we just can't go
off forever
um okay we're going Monday through
Thursday and then Friday we're heading
to stagecoach stay tuned we'll do a
patron episode from stagecoach like we
did the Coachella blog so funny what's a
g-tube years now yeah we are it's
actually so fun to vlog and I thought
you need like a big camera but we use
our phones and it's like very high
quality
yeah and it's better than your and we
could just like do it on the fly instead
of like look I guess you get more
respect if you're like holding a
but when I'm like filming a concert like
why the way I feel like such a nerd but
you know what it's for the picture I'm
and I love them
yeah so yes very regular week except for
Friday and we're gonna be patron and
story and everything from signature
recording a patron episode today that
has been a long time coming the topic is
famous couples throughout history know
it's famous couples throughout history
and I'm so excited me too let us know
some of your favorite couples throughout
history maybe we'll talk about them yes
maybe we will also my extensions are now
live I'm wearing them now Claudia has a
pair I'm bringing them to stage go check
the link in my bio RPC allcom forward
slash Jackie O get your own use code
Jackie over free shipping you're welcome
love free shipping thank you guys for
being here I'll be an amazing day and
Mo's amazing week amazing everything
amazing life you know to Adele thinking
about a job today I have a great day
guys bye
you